ce vendredi matin Blois porte les traces
des violences subies il y a quelques
heures encore les grillées de ce bureau
de poste restent fermés il a été la
cible d'assaillants Blois a connu des
violences dès la tombée de la nuit hier
on voit ici des jeunes cagoulés armés de
bars et de battes de baseball sur leur
passage la désolation voiture brûlée
vandalisée
qui auraient commencé assez tôt dans la
soirée puisque
des témoins prévus les forces de l'ordre
à préparer des cocktails Molotov et puis
assez rapidement
en tout début de soirée en fait les
événements ont commencé avec des feux de
poubelles il y a eu le scooter quelques
véhicules et puis merci monter en
puissance tout au long de la soirée et
de la nuit
vers 23 heures les individus convergent
pour s'en prendre violemment aux locaux
de la police municipale de Blois à
l'intérieur des fonctionnaires et le
directeur de cabinet du maire les yeux
rivés sur les écrans de caméras de
vidéosurveillance et personnel qui était
à l'intérieur ont eu vraiment vraiment
peur ils étaient en train de superviser
les images quand ils ont perçu une
centaine de gens cagoulés et en noir qui
se dirigeaient vers eux ils ont compris
qu'il fallait se barricader et les
assaillants on vandalisé les voitures
autour sur la rue ils ont pénétré dans
la cour
ils ont pas réussi à rentrer dans les
locaux malgré effectivement des assauts
répétés puisqu'il a fallu deux
interventions de la police nationale et
municipale pour pour mettre les
personnels qui étaient à l'intérieur en
sécurité cette attaque du poste de
police municipal est une nouveauté à
Blois qui avait connu des émeutes il y a
deux ans déjà hier 80 pompiers ont été
engagés tout au long de la nuit pour
circonscrire les différents incendies